When every effort to get your kids to bed at a reasonable hour has failed,...
...it's time to fall back on Daylight Saving Fall Back.
Yes, there's no S at the end of "Saving", it's so weird.
On November 6, by doing nothing different,...
"Put your pants on your legs."
...during your semi-dysfunctional bedtime routine,...
...you turn the clocks back an hour and your kid's asleep by eight.
No, I did not think this through.
Now, most moms will totally stress about...
...how this transition affects their baby's intricate schedule.
That's why I never got you on a schedule.
Some moms will cry that their kids are now waking up at the crack of dawn...
...but you, you look at this as an opportunity to actually be on time for preschool,...
...to be an early mom.
Hang on a sec, where is everyone?
Guys?
Oh yes, within a week, this will all start to slip away.
Your kid's looking way too awake...
...and one more TV show leads to another and you're back where you started,...
...just in time for the evil stepsibling of Daylight Saving Fall Back, Spring Forward.
Don't think about it.
Forget that I brought it up.
They say, "Even a broken clock is right twice a day."
Well, your parenting strategy is right once a year.
So, enjoy that extra hour...
"Cheers."
...and have a happy Daylight Savings, Saving, Fall Back.